foreign
[Music]
was more than just a lifeless Rock
under that bright light it could be
hiding an alien civilization
when did this alien life begin on the
moon
what would these lunar dwellers breathe
and what would our neighbors look like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if aliens lived on the moon
until Galileo showed up on the scene
with his telescope all we knew about the
moon was that it was bright and shiny
well we certainly know more now its
Origins are still a mystery
yeah we still don't know how the moon
became well the Moon
some scientists think a chunk of the
Earth broke off about four and a half
billion years ago after a violent
collision with another planet all the
debris eventually came together to form
this body
and the moon landing in 1969 did more
than Inspire Humanity to reach the Stars
it made this rock something real to
humans everywhere
but we didn't stay for long so what if
the astronauts missed something big up
there
well if we missed any signs of life it
wouldn't be the first time humans have
ignored the big picture let's be honest
climate change is real and it's only
getting worse you could think warming
temperatures and rising sea levels for
those deadly hurricanes even worse since
2020 a dozen insurance companies in
Florida have gone out of business that
means policyholders may never see a dime
to help rebuild after the storm
so what can you do well the best we can
do right now is try and limit the damage
at home with the inflation reduction act
over nine billion dollars will be given
to rebate up to 100 percent of the cost
of installing energy efficient
Electronics like solar panels battery
storage and heat pumps and it even puts
pressure on the biggest polluters on the
planet the fossil fuel industry this
legislation forces penalties on methane
leaks and even royalties on oil and gas
extraction if we don't take these steps
together now our planet could end up as
Barren as the Moon
the lunar surface is a rough place to
live without an atmosphere there's no
protection from the sun's radiation or
even a way to keep oxygen on the ground
but maybe it wasn't always like this
after that piece of Earth broke off
microscopic life like cyanobacteria
could have survived in this harsh
environment
we call this the panspermia theory the
idea that life can be transferred by
meteoroids asteroids or even spaceships
considering the moon orbits Us in the
habitable zone there could have been a
time billions of years ago when it had
fresh water
and volcanic activity could have
released the gases needed to sustain
life
so why isn't their life there now
well who's to say there isn't
when these conditions existed the moon
could have incubated life for hundreds
of millions of years before humans
existed while dinosaurs roamed our
planet the moon could have been teeming
with life that would look stranger than
some of those behemoths
the moon's magnetic field is a fraction
as powerful as the Earth's so over
millions of years solar winds Stripped
Away all of its atmosphere with nothing
to protect it life on the surface would
have to adapt to survive the sun's
intense rays
on Earth melanin in our skin protects us
from ultraviolet rays but instead of
having a darker skin tone the moon
aliens could have developed new colors
carotenoids are organic pigments found
in vegetables like carrots and they
contain cells that protect against skin
cancer
if the aliens evolved to have
carotenoids instead of melanin they
might have tough orange skin that would
resist the dangerous UV rays around them
and the difference is don't end there
since the moon's gravity is the only
one-sixth of that on Earth these aliens
could get around by jumping or gliding
but without an atmosphere holding oxygen
on the surface what would these
creatures breathe
well even with an atmosphere that's only
one hundredth as thick as ours that
doesn't mean that life can't exist
recently scientists have found a
parasite that doesn't need oxygen to
live
maybe over millions of years these
aliens could have evolved in the same
way without breathing well anything
now while this diversity of life might
exist on the surface you couldn't say
the same for the lunar oceans
I mean if they existed
while the average ocean on earth goes
down 3.7 kilometers the moon's Seas
would only have a depth of one kilometer
there's not much that could be found in
these Waters
but if life did exist on the moon how
would that have changed our history
well if these aliens had evolved before
Humanity they might have visited us
before we landed on the moon
and if they had waited until after the
space race
the increasing tensions of the Cold War
might never have happened
instead humans could have United in fear
over an invasion from a superior life
form
the militaries around the globe would
have deployed countermeasures to assess
the threats these visitors pose and as
scientists and politicians tried to
communicate with our Celestial neighbors
everyone else would be hunkered down
bracing for the worst
you know sharing our corner of the solar
system with a much more advanced
civilization might be overwhelming but
it's either that or an all-out War
and considering how much more evolved
these aliens are we might want to think
of a peaceful solution
or hey we might get along so well that
eventually our two species could become
one
what if you took it to the extreme and
made it with an alien
well brush up on your Klingon and stay
right here because that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
[Music]